MATHEMATICAL PRINCIPLES
OF
NATURAL PHILOSOPHY
Definitions
DEFINITION I
The quantity of matter is the measure of the
same, arising from its density
and bulk conjointly.
thus AIR of a double density, in a double
space, is quadruple in quantity; in a triple
space, sextuple in quantity. The same thing
is to be
understood of snow, and fine dust or powders,
that are condensed
by compression or liquefaction, and of all
bodies that are by any causes
whatever differently condensed. I have no
regard in this place to a medium,
if any such there is, that freely pervades
the interstices between the parts
of bodies. It is this quantity that I mean
hereafter everywhere under the
name of body or mass. And the same is known
by the weight of each body,
for it is proportional to the weight, as I
have found by experiments on pendulums, very
accurately made, which shall be shown hereafter.
DEFINITION II
The quantity of motion 1s the measure of the
same, arising from the
velocity and quantity of matter conjointly.
The motion of the whole is the sum of the
motions of all the parts; and
therefore in a body double in quantity, with
equal velocity, the motion is
double; with twice the velocity, it is quadruple.
DEFINITION III
The vis insita, or innate force of matter,
is a power of resisting, by which
every body, as much as in it lies, continues
in its present state, whether it
be of rest, or of moving uniformly forwards
in a right line.
This force is always proportional to the body
whose force it is and differs
nothing from the inactivity of the mass, but
in our manner of conceiving
it. A body, from the inert nature of matter,
is not without difficulty put out
of its state of rest or motion. Upon which
account, this vis insita may, by
a most significant name, be called inertia
or force of inactivity.
But a body only exerts this force when another
force, impressed upon it,
endeavors to change its condition; and the
exercise of this force may be considered as
both resistance and impulse; it is resistance
so far as the body,
for maintaining its present state, opposes
the force impressed; it is impulse
so far as the body, by not easily giving way
to the impressed force of another,
endeavors to change the state of that other.
Resistance is usually ascribed to
bodies at rest, and impulse to those in motion;
but motion and rest, as commonly conceived,
are only relatively distinguished; nor are
those bodies
always truly at rest, which commonly are taken
to be so.
DEFINITION IV
An impressed force is an action exerted upon
a body, in order to change its
state, either of rest, or of uniform motion
in aright line.
This force consists in the action only, and
remains no longer in the body
when the action is over. For a body maintains
every new state it acquires,
by its inertia only. But impressed forces
are of different origins, as from
percussion, from pressure, from centripetal
force.
DEFINITION V
A centripetal force is that by which bodies
are drawn or impelled, or any
way tend, towards a point as to a centre.
Of this sort is gravity, by which bodies tend
to the centre of the earth;
magnetism, by which iron tends to the loadstone;
and that force, whatever
it is, by which the planets are continually
drawn aside from the rectilinear
motions, which otherwise they would pursue,
and made to revolve in curvilinear orbits.
A stone, whirled about in a sling, endeavors
to recede from the
hand that turns it; and by that endeavor,
distends the sling, and that with
so much the greater force, as it is revolved
with the greater velocity, and as
soon as it is let go, flies away. That force
which opposes itself to this en-
deavor, and by which the sling continually
draws back the stone towards
the hand, and retains it in its orbit, because
it is directed to the hand as the
centre of the orbit, I call the centripetal
force. And the same thing is to be
understood of all bodies, revolved in any
orbits. They all endeavor to recede
from the centres of their orbits; and were
it not for the opposition of a con-
trary force which restrains them to, and detains
them in their orbits, which
I therefore call centripetal, would fly off
in right lines, with an uniform
motion. A projectile, if it was not for the
force of gravity, would not deviate
towards the earth, but would go off from it
in a right line, and that with an
uniform motion, if the resistance of the air
was taken away. It is by its grav-
ity that it is drawn aside continually from
its rectilinear course, and made to
deviate towards the earth, more or less, according
to the force of its gravity,
and the velocity of its motion. The less its
gravity is, or the quantity of its
matter, or the greater the velocity with which
it is projected, the less will it
deviate from a rectilinear course, and the
farther it will go. If a leaden ball,
projected from the top of a mountain by the
force of gunpowder, with a
given velocity, and in a direction parallel
to the horizon, is carried ina curved
line to the distance of two miles before it
falls to the ground; the same, if
the resistance of the air were taken away,
with a double or decuple velocity,
would fly twice or ten times as far. And by
increasing the velocity, we may at
pleasure increase the distance to which it
might be projected, and diminish
the curvature of the line which it might describe,
till at last it should fall at
the distance of 10, 30, or go degrees, or
even might go quite round the whole
earth before it falls; or lastly, so that
it might never fall to the earth, but go
forwards into the celestial spaces, and proceed
in its motion 7 infinitum.
And after the same manner that a projectile,
by the force of gravity, may
be made to revolve in an orbit, and go round
the whole earth, the moon
also, either by the force of gravity, if it
is endued with gravity, or by any
other force, that impels it towards the earth,
may be continually drawn
aside towards the earth, out of the rectilinear
way which by its innate force
it would pursue; and would be made to revolve
in the orbit which it now
describes; nor could the moon without some
such force be retained in its
orbit. If this force was too small, it would
not sufficiently turn the moon
out of a rectilinear course; if it was too
great, it would turn it too much,
and draw down the moon from its orbit towards
the earth. It is necessary
that the force be of a just quantity, and
it belongs to the mathematicians to
find the force that may serve exactly to retain
a body in a given orbit with
a given velocity; and vice versa, to determine
the curvilinear way into which
a body projected from a given place, with
a given velocity, may be made to
deviate from its natural rectilinear way,
by means of a given force.
The quantity of any centripetal force may
be considered as of three
kinds: absolute, accelerative, and motive.
DEFINITION VI
The absolute quantity of a centripetal force
is the measure of the same,
proportional to the efficacy of the cause
that propagates it from the centre,
through the spaces round about.
Thus the magnetic force is greater in one
loadstone and less in another,
according to their sizes and strength of intensity.
DEFINITION VII
The accelerative quantity of a centripetal
force is the measure of the same,
proportional to the velocity which it generates
in a given time.
Thus the force of the same loadstone is greater
at a less distance, and less
at a greater: also the force of gravity is
greater in valleys, less on tops of
exceeding high mountains; and yet less (as
shall hereafter be shown), at
greater distances from the body of the earth;
but at equal distances, it is the
same everywhere; because (taking away, or
allowing for, the resistance of
the air), it equally accelerates all falling
bodies, whether heavy or light,
great or small.
DEFINITION VIII
The motive quantity of acentripetal force
is the measure of the same, pro-
portional to the motion which it generates
in a given time.
Thus the weight is greater in a greater body,
less in a less body; and, in
the same body, it is greater near to the earth,
and less at remoter distances.
This sort of quantity is the centripetency,
or propension of the whole body
towards the centre, or, as I may say, its
weight; and it is always known by
the quantity of an equal and contrary force
just sufficient to hinder the
descent of the body.
These quantities of forces, we may, for the
sake of brevity, call by the
names of motive, accelerative, and absolute
forces; and, for the sake of distinction,
consider them with respect to the bodies that
tend to the centre,
to the places of those bodies, and to the
centre of force towards which they
tend; that is to say, I refer the motive force
to the body as an endeavor and
propensity of the whole towards a centre,
arising from the propensities of
the several parts taken together; the accelerative
force to the place of the
body, as a certain power diffused from the
centre to all places around to
move the bodies that are in them; and the
absolute force to the centre, as
endued with some cause, without which those
motive forces would not be
propagated through the spaces round about;
whether that cause be some
central body (such as is the magnet in the
centre of the magnetic force, or
the earth in the centre of the gravitating
force), or anything else that does
not yet appear. For I here design only to
give a mathematical notion of
those forces, without considering their physical
causes and seats.
Wherefore the accelerative force will stand
in the same relation to the
motive, as celerity does to motion. For the
quantity of motion arises from
the celerity multiplied by the quantity of
matter; and the motive force
arises from the accelerative force multiplied
by the same quantity of matter.
For the sum of the actions of the accelerative
force, upon the several particles of the body,
is the motive force of the whole. Hence it
is, that near the
surface of the earth, where the accelerative
gravity, or force productive of
gravity, in all bodies is the same, the motive
gravity o. the weight is as the
body; but if we should ascend to higher regions,
where the accelerative
gravity is less, the weight would be equally
diminished, and would always
be as the product of the body, by the accelerative
gravity. So in those re-
gions, where the accelerative gravity is diminished
into one-half, the weight
of a body two or three times less, will be
four or six times less.
I likewise call attractions and impulses,
in the same sense, accelerative,
and motive; and use the words attraction,
impulse, or propensity of any
sort towards a centre, promiscuously, and
indifferently, one for another;
considering those forces not physically, but
mathematically: wherefore the
reader is not to imagine that by those words
I anywhere take upon me to
define the kind, or the manner of any action,
the causes or the physical
reason thereof, or that I attribute forces,
in a true and physical sense, to
certain centres (which are only mathematical
points); when at any time I
happen to speak of centres as attracting,
or as endued with attractive powers.
SCHOLIUM
Hitherto I have laid down the definitions
of such words as are less
known, and explained the sense in which I
would have them to be under-
stood in the following discourse. I do not
define time, space, place, and
motion, as being well known to all. Only I
must observe, that the common
people conceive those quantities under no
other notions but from the relation they bear
to sensible objects. And thence arise certain
prejudices, for
the removing of which it will be convenient
to distinguish them into absolute and relative,
true and apparent, mathematical and common.
I. Absolute, true, and mathematical time,
of itself} and from its own
nature, flows equably without relation to
anything external, and by another
name is called duration: relative, apparent,
and common time, is some sensible and external
(whether accurate or unequable) measure of
duration by
the means of motion, which is commonly used
instead of true time; such
as an hour, a day, a month, a year.
II. Absolute space, in its own nature, without
relation to anything exter-
nal, remains always similar and immovable.
Relative space is some movable
dimension or measure of the absolute spaces;
which our senses determine
by its position to bodies; and which is commonly
taken for immovable
space; such is the dimension of a subterraneous,
an aerial, or celestial space,
determined by its position in respect of the
earth. Absolute and relative
space are the same in figure and magnitude;
but they do not remain always
numerically the same. For if the earth, for
instance, moves, a space of our
air, which relatively and in respect of the
earth remains always the same,
will at one time be one part of the absolute
space into which the air passes;
at another time it will be another part of
the same, and so, absolutely under-
stood, it will be continually changed.
III. Place is a part of space which a body
takes up, and is according to the
space, either absolute or relative. I say,
a part of space; not the situation, nor
the external surface of the body. For the
places of equal solids are always
equal; but their surfaces, by reason of their
dissimilar figures, are often
unequal. Positions properly have no quantity,
nor are they so much the
places themselves, as the properties of places.
The motion of the whole is
the same with the sum of the motions of the
parts; that is, the translation
of the whole, out of its place, is the same
thing with the sum of the translations of
the parts out of their places
Absolute time, in astronomy, is distinguished
from relative, by the equation or correction
of the apparent time. For the natural days
are truly un-equal, though they are commonly
considered as equal, and used for a measure
of time; astronomers correct this inequality
that they may measure the
celestial motions by a more accurate time.
It may be, that there is no such
thing as an equable motion, whereby time may
be accurately measured.
All motions may be accelerated and retarded,
but the flowing of absolute
time is not liable to any change. The duration
or perseverance of the existence of things
remains the same, whether the motions are
swift or slow, or
none at all: and therefore this duration ought
to be distinguished from what
are only sensible measures thereof; and from
which we deduce it, by means
of the astronomical equation. The necessity
of this equation, for determining the times
of a phenomenon, is evinced as well from the
experiments
of the pendulum clock, as by eclipses of the
satellites of Jupiter.
As the order of the parts of time is immutable,
so also is the order of the
parts of space. Suppose those parts to be
moved out of their places, and
they will be moved (if the expression may
be allowed) out of themselves.
For times and spaces are, as it were, the
places as well of themselves as of
all other things. All things are placed in
time as to order of succession; and
in space as to order of situation. It is from
their essence or nature that they
are places; and that the primary places of
things should be movable, is
absurd. These are therefore the absolute places;
and translations out of
those places, are the only absolute motions.
But because the parts of space cannot be seen,
or distinguished from one
another by our senses, therefore in their
stead we use sensible measures of
them. For from the positions and distances
of things from any body considered as immovable,
we define all places; and then with respect
to such
places, we estimate all motions, considering
bodies as transferred from some
of those places into others. And so, instead
of absolute places and motions,
we use relative ones; and that without any
inconvenience in common
affairs; but in philosophical disquisitions,
we ought to abstract from our
senses, and consider things themselves, distinct
from what are only sensible
measures of them. For it may be that there
is no body really at rest, to which
the places and motions of others may be referred.
But we may distinguish rest and motion, absolute
and relative, one from
the other by their properties, causes, and
effects. It is a property of rest, that
bodies really at rest do rest in respect to
one another. And therefore as it is
possible, that in the remote regions of the
fixed stars, or perhaps far beyond
them, there may be some body absolutely at
rest; but impossible to know,
from the position of bodies to one another
in our regions, whether any of
these do keep the same position to that remote
body, it follows that absolute
rest cannot be determined from the position
of bodies in our regions.
It is a property of motion, that the parts,
which retain given positions to
their wholes, do partake of the motions of
those wholes. For all the parts
of revolving bodies endeavor to recede from
the axis of motion; and the
impetus of bodies moving forwards arises from
the joint impetus of all the
parts. Therefore, if surrounding bodies are
moved, those that are relatively
at rest within them will partake of their
motion. Upon which account, the
true and absolute motion of a body cannot
be determined by the translation
of it from those which only seem to rest;
for the external bodies ought not
only to appear at rest, but to be really at
rest. For otherwise, all included
bodies, besides their translation from near
the surrounding ones, partake
likewise of their true motions; and though
that translation were not made,
they would not be really at rest, but only
seem to be so. For the surrounding
bodies stand in the like relation to the surrounded
as the exterior part of a
whole does to the interior, or as the shell
does to the kernel; but if the shell
moves, the kernel will also move, as being
part of the whole, without any
removal from near the shell.
A property, near akin to the preceding, is
this, that if a place is moved,
whatever is placed therein moves along with
it; and therefore a body, which
is moved from a place in motion, partakes
also of the motion of its place.
Upon which account, all motions, from places
in motion, are no other than
parts of entire and absolute motions; and
every entire motion is composed
of the motion of the body out of its first
place, and the motion of this place
out of its place; and so on, until we come
to some immovable place, as in
the before-mentioned example of the sailor.
Wherefore, entire and absolute motions can
be no otherwise determined than by immovable
places;
and for that reason I did before refer those
absolute motions to immovable
places, but relative ones to movable places.
Now no other places are immovable but those
that, from infinity to infinity, do all retain
the same given
position one to another ; and upon this account
must ever remain unmoved;
and do thereby constitute immovable space.
The causes by which true and relative motions
are distinguished, one
from the other, are the forces impressed upon
bodies to generate motion.
True motion is neither generated nor altered,
but by some force impressed
upon the body moved; but relative motion may
be generated or altered
without any force impressed upon the body.
For it is sufficient only to
impress some force on other bodies with which
the former is compared, that
by their giving way, that relation may be
changed, in which the relative
rest or motion of this other body did consist.
Again, true motion suffers
always some change from any force impressed
upon the moving body;
_ but relative motion does not necessarily
undergo any change by such forces.
For if the same forces are likewise impressed
on those other bodies, with
which the comparison is made, that the relative
position may be preserved,
then that condition will be preserved in which
the relative motion consists.
And therefore any relative motion may be changed
when the true motion
remains unaltered, and the relative may be
preserved when the true suffers
some change. Thus, true motion by no means
consists in such relations.
The effects which distinguish absolute from
relative motion are, the
forces of receding from the axis of circular
motion. For there are no such
forces in a circular motion purely relative,
but in a true and absolute circular
motion, they are greater or less, according
to the quantity of the motion.
If a vessel, hung by a long cord, is so often
turned about that the cord is
strongly twisted, then filled with water,
and held at rest together with the
water ; thereupon, by the sudden action of
another force, it is whirled about
the contrary way, and while the cord is untwisting
itself, the vessel continues for some time
in this motion; the surface of the water will
at first be
plain, as before the vessel began to move;
but after that, the vessel, by gradually communicating
its motion to the water, will make it begin
sensibly
to revolve, and recede by little and little
from the middle, and ascend to the
sides of the vessel, forming itself into a
concave figure (as I have experienced), and
the swifter the motion becomes, the higher
will the water rise,
till at last, performing its revolutions in
the same times with the vessel, it
becomes relatively at rest in it. This ascent
of the water shows its endeavor
to recede from the axis of its motion; and
the true and absolute circular
motion of the water, which is here directly
contrary to the relative, becomes
known, and may be measured by this endeavor.
At first, when the relative
motion of the water in the vessel was greatest,
it produced no endeavor to
recede from the axis; the water showed no
tendency to the circumference,
nor any ascent towards the sides of the vessel,
but remained of a plain surface, and therefore
its true circular motion had not yet begun.
But after-
wards, when the relative motion of the water
had decreased, the ascent
thereof towards the sides of the vessel proved
its endeavor to recede from
the axis; and this endeavor showed the real
circular motion of the water
continually increasing, till it had acquired
its greatest quantity, when the
water rested relatively in the vessel. And
therefore this endeavor does not
depend upon any translation of the water in
respect of the ambient bodies,
nor can true circular motion be defined by
such translation. There is only
one real circular motion of any one revolving
body, corresponding to only
one power of endeavoring to recede from its
axis of motion, as its proper
and adequate effect; but relative motions,
in one and the same body, are
innumerable, according to the various relations
it bears to external bodies,
and, like other relations, are altogether
destitute of any real effect, any other-
wise than they may perhaps partake of that
one only true motion. And
therefore in their system who suppose that
our heavens, revolving below
the sphere of the fixed stars, carry the planets
along with them; the several
parts of those heavens, and the planets, which
are indeed relatively at rest
in their heavens, do yet really move. For
they change their position one to
another (which never happens to bodies truly
at rest), and being carried
together with their heavens, partake of their
motions, and as parts of revolving wholes,
endeavor to recede from the axis of their
motions.
Wherefore relative quantities are not the
quantities themselves, whose
names they bear, but those sensible measures
of them (either accurate or
inaccurate), which are commonly used instead
of the measured quantities
themselves. And if the meaning of words is
to be determined by their use,
then by the names time, space, place, and
motion, their [sensible] measures
are properly to be understood; and the expression
will be unusual, and
purely mathematical, if the measured quantities
themselves are meant. On
this account, those violate the accuracy of
language, which ought to be kept
precise, who interpret these words for the
measured quantities. Nor do those
less defile the purity of mathematical and
philosophical truths, who con-
found real quantities with their relations
and sensible measures.
It is indeed a matter of great difficulty
to discover, and effectually to distinguish,
the true motions of particular bodies from
the apparent; because
the parts of that immovable space, in which
those motions are performed,
do by no means come under the observation
of our senses. Yet the thing is
not altogether desperate; for we have some
arguments to guide us, partly
from the apparent motions, which are the differences
of the true motions;
partly from the forces, which are the causes
and effects of the true motions.
For instance, if two globes, kept at a given
distance one from the other by
means of a cord that connects them, were revolved
about their common
centre of gravity, we might, from the tension
of the cord, discover the
endeavor of the globes to recede from the
axis of their motion, and from
thence we might compute the quantity of their
circular motions. And then
if any equal forces should be impressed at
once on the alternate faces of the
globes to augment or diminish their circular
motions, from the increase or
decrease of the tension of the cord, we might
infer the increment or decrement of their
motions; and thence would be found on what
faces those
forces ought to be impressed, that the motions
of the globes might be most
augmented; that is, we might discover their
hindmost faces, or those which,
in the circular motion, do follow. But the
faces which follow being known,
and consequently the opposite ones that precede,
we should likewise know
the determination of their motions. And thus
we might find both the quantity and the determination
of this circular motion, even in an immense
vacuum, where there was nothing external or
sensible with which the
globes could be compared. But now, if in that
space some remote bodies
were placed that kept always a given position
one to another, as the fixed
stars do in our regions, we could not indeed
determine from the relative
translation of the globes among those bodies,
whether the motion did
belong to the globes or to the bodies. But
if we observed the cord, and found
that its tension was that very tension which
the motions of the globes required, we might
conclude the motion to be in the globes, and
the bodies
to be at rest; and then, lastly, from the
translation of the globes among the
bodies, we should find the determination of
their motions. But how we are
to obtain the true motions from their causes,
effects, and apparent differences, and the
converse, shall be explained more at large
in the following
treatise. For to this end it was that I composed
it.
AXIOMS, OR
LAWS OF MOTION
LAW I
Every body continues in its state of rest,
or of uniform motion in a right
line, unless it is compelled to change that
state by forces impressed upon it.
PROJECTILES continue in their motions, so
far as they are not retarded
Pp by the resistance of the air, or impelled
downwards by the force of
gravity. A top, whose parts by their cohesion
are continually drawn
aside from rectilinear motions, does not cease
its rotation, otherwise than
as it is retarded by the air. The greater
bodies of the planets and comets,
meeting with less resistance in freer spaces,
preserve their motions both
progressive and circular for a much longer
time.
LAW II
The change of motion is proportional to the
motive force impressed; and
1s made in the direction of the right line
in which that force is impressed.
If any force generates a motion, a double
force will generate double the
motion, a triple force triple the motion,
whether that force be impressed
altogether and at once, or gradually and successively.
And this motion
(being always directed the same way with the
generating force), if the
body moved before, is added to or subtracted
from the former motion,
according as they directly conspire with or
are directly contrary to each
other; or obliquely joined, when they are
oblique, so as to produce a new
motion compounded from the determination of
both.
LAW III
To every action there is always opposed an
equal reaction: or, the mutual
actions of two bodies upon each other are
always equal, and directed to
contrary parts.
Whatever draws or presses another is as much
drawn or pressed by that
other. If you press a stone with your finger,
the finger is also pressed by the
stone. If a horse draws a stone tied to a
rope, the horse (if I may so say) will
be equally drawn back towards the stone; for
the distended rope, by the
same endeavor to relax or unbend itself, will
draw the horse as much
towards the stone as it does the stone towards
the horse, and will obstruct
the progress of the one as much as it advances
that of the other. If a body
impinge upon another, and by its force change
the motion of the other, that
body also (because of the equality of the
mutual pressure) will undergo an
equal change, in its own motion, towards the
contrary part. The changes
made by these actions are equal, not in the
velocities but in the motions of
bodies; that is to say, if the bodies are
not hindered by any other impedi-
ments. For, because the motions are equally
changed, the changes of the
velocities made towards contrary parts are
inversely proportional to the
bodies. This law takes place also in attractions,
as will be proved in the next
Scholium.
COROLLARY I
A body, acted on by two forces simultaneously,
will describe the diagonal
of a parallelogram in the same time as it
would describe the sides by those
forces separately.
COROLLARY II
And hence is explained the composition of
any one direct force AD, out of
any two oblique forces AC and CD; and, on
the contrary, the resolution of
any one direct force AD into two oblique forces
AC and CD: which composition and resolution
are abundantly confirmed from mechanics.
COROLLARY III
The quantity of motion, which is obtained
by taking the sum of the motions
directed towards the same parts, and the difference
of those that are directed
to contrary parts, suffers no change from
the action of bodies among themselves.
COROLLARY IV
The common centre of gravity of two or more
bodies does not alter its state
of motion or rest by the actions of the bodies
among themselves; and there-
fore the common centre of gravity of all bodies
acting upon each other
(excluding external actions and impediments)
is either at rest, or moves
uniformly in a right line.
COROLLARY V
The motions of bodies included in a given
space are the same among them-
selves, whether that space 1s at rest, or
moves uniformly forwards in aright
line without any circular motion.
COROLLARY VI
If bodies, moved in any manner among themselves,
are urged in the direction of parallel lines
by equal accelerative forces, they will all
continue to
move among themselves, after the same manner
as if they had not been
urged by those forces.
SCHOLIUM
Hitherto I have laid down such principles
as have been received by mathematicians, and
are confirmed by abundance of experiments.
By the first
two Laws and the first two Corollaries, Galileo
discovered that the descent
of bodies varied as the square of the time
and that the motion of projectiles was in
the curve of a parabola; experience
agreeing with both, unless so far as these
motions are a little retarded by the
resistance of the air. When a body is faliing,
the uniform force of its gravity
acting equally, impresses, in equal intervals
of time, equal forces upon that
body, and therefore generates equal velocities;
and in the whole time im-
presses a whole force, and generates a whole
velocity proportional to the
time. And the spaces described in proportional
times are as the product of
the velocities and the times; that is, as
the squares of the times. And when
a body is thrown upwards, its uniform gravity
impresses forces and reduces
velocities proportional to the times; and
the times of ascending to the great-
est heights are as the velocities to be taken
away, and those heights are as the
product of the velocities and the times, or
as the squares of the velocities.
And if a body be projected in any direction,
the motion arising from its
projection is compounded with the motion arising
from its gravity. Thus,
if the body A by its motion of projection
alone could describe in a given
time the right line AB, and with its motion
of falling alone could describe
in the same time the altitude AC; complete
the parallelogram ABCD, and
the body by that compounded motion will at
the end of the time be found
in the place D; and the curved line AED, which
B that body describes, will be a parabola,
to which the right line AB will be a tangent
at A; and whose
ordinate BD will be as the square of the line
AB.
On the same Laws and Corollaries depend those
things which have been demonstrated concerning
the times of the vibration of pendulums, and
are confirmed by the daily experiments of
pendulum clocks. By the same, together with
Law III, Sir
Christopher Wren, Dr. Wallis, and Mr. Huygens,
the greatest geometers of our times, did severally
determine the rules of
the impact and reflection of hard bodies,
and about the same time communicated their
discoveries to the Royal Society, exactly
agreeing among
themselves as to those rules. Dr. Wallis,
indeed, was somewhat earlier in
the publication; then followed Sir Christopher
Wren, and, lastly, Mr. Huygens. But Sir Christopher
Wren confirmed the truth of the thing before
the Royal Society by the experiments on pendulums,
which M. Mariotte
soon after thought fit to explain in a treatise
entirely upon that subject.
But to bring this experiment to an accurate
agreement with the theory, we
are to have due regard as well to the resistance
of the air as to the elastic
force of the concurring bodies.
Let the spherical bodies A, B be
suspended by the parallel and
equal strings AC, BD, from the
centres C, D. About these centres, with those
lengths as radii,
describe the semicircles EAF, on
GBH, bisected respectively by
the radii CA, DB. Bring the
body A to any point R of the arc EAF, and
(withdrawing the body B) let
it go from thence, and after one oscillation
suppose it to return to the point
V: then RV will be the retardation arising
from the resistance of the air.
Of this RV let ST be a fourth part, situated
in the middle, namely, so that
RS=TV,
and
RS : ST =3:2,
then will ST represent very nearly the retardation
during the descent from
S to A. Restore the body B to its place: and,
supposing the body A to be let
fall from the point S, the velocity thereof
in the place of reflection A, with-
out sensible error, will be the same as if
it had descended in vacuo from the
point T. Upon which account this velocity
may be represented by the chord
of the arc TA. For it is a proposition well
known to geometers, that the
velocity of a pendulous body in the lowest
point is as the chord of the arc
which it has described in its descent. After
reflection, suppose the body A
comes to the place s, and the body B to the
place &. Withdraw the body B,
and find the place v, from which if the body
A, being let go, should after
one oscillation return to the place r, st
may be a fourth part of rv, so placed
in the middle thereof as to leave rs equal
to tv, and let the chord of the arc
tA represent the velocity which the body A
had in the place A immediately
after reflection. For t will be the true and
correct place to which the body A
should have ascended, if the resistance of
the air had been taken off. In the
same way we are to correct the place & to
which the body B ascends, by find-
ing the place / to which it should have ascended
im vacuo. And thus every-
thing may be subjected to experiment, in the
same manner as if we were
really placed 1m vacuo. These things being
done, we are to take the product
(if I may so say) of the body A, by the chord
of the arc TA (which represents its velocity),
that we may have its motion in the place A
immediately
before reflection; and then by the chord of
the arc zA, that we may have its
motion in the place A immediately after reflection.
And so we are to take
the product of the body B by the chord of
the arc B/, that we may have the
motion of the same immediately after reflection.
And in like manner, when
two bodies are let go together from different
places, we are to find the
motion of each, as well before as after reflection;
and then we may compare
the motions between themselves, and collect
the effects of the reflection.
Thus trying the thing with pendulums of ro
feet, in unequal as well as
equal bodies, and making the bodies to concur
after a descent through large
spaces, as of 8, 12, or 16 feet, I found always,
without an error of 3 inches,
that when the bodies concurred together directly,
equal changes towards
the contrary parts were produced in their
motions, and, of consequence,
that the action and reaction were always equal.
As if the body A impinged
upon the body B at rest with 9 parts of motion,
and losing 7, proceeded
after reflection with 2, the body B was carried
backwards with those 7 parts.
If the bodies concurred with contrary motions,
A with 12 parts of motion,
and B with 6, then if A receded with 2, B
receded with 8; namely, with a
deduction of 14 parts of motion on each side.
For from the motion of A
subtracting 12 parts, nothing will remain;
but subtracting 2 parts more, a
motion will be generated of 2 parts towards
the contrary way; and so, from
the motion of the body B of 6 parts, subtracting
14 parts, a motion is gene-
rated of 8 parts towards the contrary way.
But if the bodies were made both
to move towards the same way, A, the swifter,
with 14 parts of motion, B,
the slower, with 5, and after reflection A
went on with 5, B likewise went on
with 14 parts; g parts being transferred from
A to B. And so in other cases.
By the meeting and collision of bodies, the
quantity of motion, obtained
from the sum of the motions directed towards
the same way, or from the
difference of those that were directed towards
contrary ways, was never
changed. For the error of an inch or two in
measures may be easily ascribed
to the difficulty of executing everything
with accuracy. It was not easy to
let go the two pendulumss so exactly together
that the bodies should impinge
one upon the other in the lowermost place
AB; nor to mark the places s,
and k, to which the bodies ascended after
impact. Nay, and some errors,
too, might have happened from the unequal
density of the parts of the
pendulous bodies themselves, and from the
irregularity of the texture proceeding from
other causes.
But to prevent an objection that may perhaps
be alleged against the rule,
for the proof of which this experiment was
made, as if this rule did suppose that the
bodies were either absolutely hard, or at
least perfectly elastic
(whereas no such bodies are to be found in
Nature), I must add, that the
experiments we have been describing, by no
means depending upon that
quality of hardness, do succeed as well in
soft as in hard bodies. For if the
rule is to be tried in bodies not perfectly
hard, we are only to diminish the
reflection in such a certain proportion as
the quantity of the elastic force
requires. By the theory of Wren and Huygens,
bodies absolutely hard re-
turn one from another with the same velocity
with which they meet. But
this may be affirmed with more certainty of
bodies perfectly elastic. In
bodies imperfectly elastic the velocity of
the return is to be diminished
together with the elastic force; because that
force (except when the parts
of bodies are bruised by their impact, or
suffer some such extension as hap-
pens under the strokes of a hammer) is (as
far as I can perceive) certain
and determined, and makes the bodies to return
one from the other with
a relative velocity, which is in a given ratio
to that relative velocity with
which they met. This I tried in balls of wool,
made up tightly, and strongly
compressed. For, first, by letting go the
pendulous bodies, and measuring
their reflection, | determined the quantity
of their elastic force; and then,
according to this force, estimated the reflections
that ought to happen in
other cases of impact. And with this computation
other experiments made
afterwards did accordingly agree; the balls
always receding one from the
other with a relative velocity, which was
to the relative velocity with which
they met as about 5 to g. Balls of steel returned
with almost the same
velocity; those of cork with a velocity something
less; but in balls of glass
the proportion was as about 15 to 16. And
thus the third Law, so far as it
regards percussions and reflections, is proved
by a theory exactly agreeing
with experience.
In attractions, I briefly demonstrate the
thing after this manner. Suppose
an obstacle is interposed to hinder the meeting
of any two bodies A, B,
attracting one the other: then if either body,
as A, is more attracted towards
the other body B, than that other body B is
towards the first body A, the
obstacle will be more strongly urged by the
pressure of the body A than by
the pressure of the body B, and therefore
will not remain in equilibrium:
but the stronger pressure will prevail, and
will make the system of the two
bodies, together with the obstacle, to move
directly towards the parts on
which B lies; and in free spaces, to go forwards
in infinitum with a motion
continually accelerated; which is absurd and
contrary to the first Law. For,
by the first Law, the system ought to continue
in its state of rest, or of
moving uniformly forwards in a right line;
and therefore the bodies must
equally press the obstacle, and be equally
attracted one by the other. I made
the experiment on the loadstone and iron.
If these, placed apart in proper
vessels, are made to float by one another
in standing water, neither of them
will propel the other; but, by being equally
attracted, they will sustain each
other’s pressure, and rest at last in an
equilibrium.
So the gravitation between the earth and its
parts is mutual. Let the earth
FI be cut by any plane EG into two parts EGF
and EGI, and their weights
one towards the other will be mutually equal.
For if by another plane HK,
parallel to the former EG, the greater part
EGI is cut into two parts EGKH
and HKI, whereof HKI is equal to the part
EFG, first cut off, it is evident that the
middle
part EGKH will have no propension by its
proper weight towards either side, but will
hang as it were, and rest in an equilibrium
between both. But the one extreme part HKI
will with its whole weight bear upon and
press the middle part towards the other extreme
part EGF; and therefore the force with
which EGI, the sum of the parts HKI and EGKH,
tends towards the third
part EGF, is equal to the weight of the part
HK], that is, to the weight of
the third part EGF. And therefore the weights
of the two parts EGI and
EGF, one towards the other, are equal, as
I was to prove. And indeed if those
weights were not equal, the whole earth floating
in the nonresisting ether
would give way to the greater weight, and,
retiring from it, would be carried
off in infinitum.
And as those bodies are equipollent in the
impact and reflection, whose
velocities are inversely as their innate forces,
so in the use of mechanic instruments those
agents are equipollent, and mutually sustain
each the contrary
pressure of the other, whose velocities, estimated
according to the determination of the forces,
are inversely as the forces.
So those weights are of equal force to move
the arms of a balance, which
during the play of the balance are inversely
as their velocities upwards and
downwards; that is, if the ascent or descent
is direct, those weights are of
equal force, which are inversely as the distances
of the points at which they
are suspended from the axis of the balance;
but if they are turned aside by
the interposition of oblique planes, or other
obstacles, and made to ascend
or descend obliquely, those bodies will be
equipollent, which are inversely
as the heights of their ascent and descent
taken according to the perpen-
dicular; and that on account of the determination
of gravity downwards.
And in like manner in the pulley, or in a
combination of pulleys, the
force of a hand drawing the rope directly,
which is to the weight, whether
ascending directly or obliquely, as the velocity
of the perpendicular ascent
of the weight to the velocity of the hand
that draws the rope, will sustain
the weight.
In clocks and such like instruments, made
up from a combination of
wheels, the contrary forces that promote and
impede the motion of the
wheels, if they are inversely as the velocities
of the parts of the wheel on
which they are impressed, will mutually sustain
each other.
The force of the screw to press a body is
to the force of the hand that
turns the handles by which it is moved as
the circular velocity of the handle
in that part where it is impelled by the hand
is to the progressive velocity
of the screw towards the pressed body.
The forces by which the wedge presses or drives
the two parts of the
wood it cleaves are to the force of the mallet
upon the wedge as the progress
of the wedge in the direction of the force
impressed upon it by the mallet
is to the velocity with which the parts of
the wood yield to the wedge, in
the direction of lines perpendicular to the
sides of the wedge. And the like
account is to be given of all machines.
The power and use of machines consist only
in this, that by diminishing
the velocity we may augment the force, and
the contrary; from whence, in
all sorts of proper machines, we have the
solution of this problem: To move
a given weight with a given power, or with
a given force to overcome any
other given resistance. For if machines are
so contrived that the velocities
of the agent and resistant are inversely as
their forces, the agent will just
sustain the resistant, but with a greater
disparity of velocity will overcome
it. So that if the disparity of velocities
is so great as to overcome all that
resistance which commonly arises either from
the friction of contiguous
bodies as they slide by one another, or from
the cohesion of continuous
bodies that are to be separated, or from the
weights of bodies to be raised,
the excess of the force remaining, after all
those resistances are overcome,
will produce an acceleration of motion proportional
thereto, as well in the
parts of the machine as in the resisting body.
But to treat of mechanics is not my present
business. | was aiming only to show by those
examples the
great extent and certainty of the third Law
of Motion. For if we estimate
the action of the agent from the product of
its force and velocity, and like-
wise the reaction of the impediment from the
product of the velocities of its
several parts, and the forces of resistance
arising from the friction, cohesion,
weight, and acceleration of those parts, the
action and reaction in the use
of all sorts of machines will be found always
equal to one another. And
so far as the action is propagated by the
intervening instruments, and at
last impressed upon the resisting body, the
ultimate action will be always
contrary to the reaction.